bonsoir
je suis venu ce soir vous parler de la
crise mondiale de l'eau un sujet
et sur lequel je travaille depuis
maintenant plus de dix ans et qui m'a
amené à aller visiter de nombreux pays
et a essayé de comprendre et de trouver
des solutions aux nombreux problèmes qui
se posent
je voudrais d'abord vous emmener en
chine où moi-même en 1997
je me suis retrouvé à essayer de
comprendre pourquoi le fleuve jaune
était victime de pénuries d'eau qui
allait en s'aggravant
en 1997 le fleuve jaune a été à sec sur
700 km depuis son embouchure et pendant
200 jours de l'année imaginez la scène 1
sec pendant autant de temps et vous
pouvez comprendre les difficultés
auxquelles le pays était confronté avec
premièrement des impacts importants sur
toute l'agriculture de l'aval du bassin
du fleuve jaune
les agriculteurs dans cette région ont
besoin d'irriguer mais comme il n'y
avait plus assez d'eau et bien la
plupart des cultures à l'exception du
petit corridor autour du fleuve était
vraiment en très mauvais état
et puis deuxième conséquences auxquelles
on ne pense pas forcément toute la
production piscicole et de fruits de mer
ou dans le delta du fleuve jaune qui a
besoin d'eau douce pour bien fonctionner
et est également en train de péricliter
et c'était toutes les villes de l'est de
la chine qui voyait menacé une partie de
leur nourriture dans cette situation du
fleuve jaune qui résultent de pompage
très important
tout le long du fleuve et non pas
particulièrement une sécheresse eh bien
c'est ce qu'on observe aujourd'hui dans
de nombreux fleuves du monde et cette
situation j'ai essayé de la comprendre
et la première chose qui m'a frappé
c'est
énorme quantité d'eau qui est nécessaire
pour produire notre alimentation pour
produire les végétaux d'abord qui
servent à notre alimentation parce que
un végétal ne fonctionne bien que s'il a
de quoi transpirer suffisamment que s'il
a effectivement beaucoup d'eau
quelques exemples tout d'abord avec des
produits végétaux pour produire un kilo
de blé
il faut 1000 litres d'eau il en va de
même de la plupart des céréales à
l'exception du riz qui lui demande
pratiquement le double demi litre d'eau
les produits végétaux quant à eux une
requiert en général entre 200 et 500
litres d'eau des chiffres remarquer
qu'ils sont très élevés surtout quand on
les compare aux besoins quotidiens
sanitaire qui sans de quelques dizaines
de litres va peut-être une centaine de
litres pour chacun d'entre nous mais ce
n'est pas tout nous ne mangeons pas du
blé nous mangeons pas du tournesol
nous mangeons général du pain de l'huile
de tournesol et puis nous mangeons de
nombreux produits qui ont été
transformés en particulier des céréales
transformées en viande
aujourd'hui dans le monde la moitié ou
peut-être plus dans certains pays des
céréales qui sont produites servent à
fabriquer les animaux donc
les quantités d'eau nécessaires pour ses
produits transformés sont encore bien
plus important un kilo de pain coûte
1600 litres d'eau un kilo de poulet de
viande de poulet coûte 3000 litres d'eau
un kilo de viande de boeuf coûte 15
mille litres d'eau toute cette eau nous
ne la voyons pas lorsque nous consommons
un produit elle nous est totalement
cachée et dans le jargon de l'eau parce
qu'elle est cachée justement on a appelé
cette eau l'eau virtuelle
chaque jour nous devons pour nous
nourrir
en tant que français consommer cinq
mille litres d'eau virtuelle une
quantité encore une fois très
impressionnante
à l'échelle mondiale c'est 3000 litres
qui sont nécessaires en moyenne
parce que dans de nombreux pays bien on
mange moins de viande on mange moins de
produits transformés qui si lorsqu'on
veut se rendre compte de la quantité
d'eau qui est nécessaire pour produire
l'ensemble de la nourriture du monde
eh bien on arrive à des chiffres
absolument que le saut alors comme c'est
assez compliqué de se rendre compte de
ces de ces quantités d'eaux énormes
nécessaires
j'ai tendance à a utilisé une unité qui
est un petit peu plus simple et qui est
la quantité d'eau qui arrivent chaque
année en egypte à travers le nil le nil
c'est un des pays les uns des fleuves
les plus grands du monde
il draine toute l'afrique de l'est et si
on veut s'imaginer tout la quantité
d'eau qu'il amène chaque année eh bien
ils amènent un canal de 100 mètres de
large d'un mètre de profondeur
et de 500 mille kilomètres de long plus
de dix fois le tour de la terre c'est ce
qu'amène un nil en egypte
et bien si on veut représenter la
quantité d'eau qui est nécessaire à
produire la totalité de notre
alimentation
et bien c'est 180 il qu'il faut au total
90% de l'eau plus nous utilisons est en
fête de l'eau qui sert à produire notre
alimentation
les autres 10% servent à produire les
produits industriels est également
servent à notre eau potable
mais ce n'est pas tout aujourd'hui une
bonne partie de l'alimentation que nous
mangeons et transférés entre pays à
travers le commerce international et
avec ce commerce international et bien
une bonne partie de l'eau virtuelle et
transféré et transportés entre les pays
prenons l'exemple d'un français en
france l'agriculture utilise à peu près
4000 litres d'eau pour chacun d'entre
nous par jour mais sur ces 4000 litres
et bien nous en exportons 3000 mais nous
il nous en reste donc 1000 mais nous on
ré important ensuite d'autres pays
4000 litres et donc nous en avait bien
5000 à notre disposition par jour d'où
vient cette eau là la surprise est
encore assez grande
une partie de cette eau vient de nos
pays voisins et notamment d'espagne mais
une grande partie de cette eau vient
aussi d'autres pays et de pays beaucoup
plus lointain du brésil du de
l'ouzbékistan du
hadji qui ce temps de chine d'inde parce
que nos importations de produits
alimentaires sont surtout du soja du
coton qui constitue la plus grande
partie de notre de notre consommation en
eau virtuelle importés globalement sur
en france la consommation totale d'eau
de tous les français par an et de 2000
et sur ces deux nil près de la moitié
est en fait consacrée à des produits
alimentaires à des produits animaux
pardon tout c'est toute cette eau si
loin cela représente au niveau mondial
eh bien elles représentent elles aussi
une quantité d'eau énorme
cette eau transporter entre pays en fait
on sait on a fait des estimations s'est
rendu compte qu'elle représentait 30
milles soit à peu près un cinquième de
toute la quantité d'eau nécessaire à
produire notre alimentation nous sommes
donc actuellement tous interconnectés
par un gigantesque réseau d'irrigation
qui interconnecte les différents un pays
à travers l'eau virtuelle qui est
échangé 7,7 et ces échanges il normes et
le fait que beaucoup de ses taux bien de
pays où il ya déjà des pénuries doivent
nous questionner est-ce que ça va être
durable est ce que nous faisons bien
d'avoir une grande partie de notre eau
dépendante de l'agriculture d'autres
pays
une question évidemment très importante
pour dans l'avenir sachant qu'il reste
encore deux milliards d'habitants à
accueillir sur notre planète
et puis c'est tout et ces échanges ont
des conséquences géopolitiques très
importante parce que pour beaucoup de
pays notamment les pays arides et bien
il faut importer de la nourriture parce
qu'il n'y a simplement pas assez d'eau
pour la produire sur dans le pays lui
même
c'est le cas en particulier de tous les
pays de la rive sud méditerranéenne le
maroc l'algérie la tunisie l'egypte tous
importe aujourd'hui déjà plus de 50% de
leurs céréales et lorsqu'on regarde les
évolutions on s'aperçoit que ces
importations augmentent continuellement
et il n'est pas difficile de prévoir qu
avec la croissance démographique auquel
ils font face actuellement
eh bien ils vont continuer à importer de
plus en plus d'eau mais ce qui est
encore une fois très surprenant c'est
que tous les échanges ne se font pas
dans le sens auquel on s'attend par
exemple en chine justement
et bien c'est le nord de la chic et plus
aride qui nourrit le sud de la chine qui
est plus humide qui est très étrange
en fait c'est pratiquement un fleuve
d'eau virtuelle égal à l'ensemble des
ressources du fleuve jaune qui est
actuellement transférés vers le sud de
la chine et vers les villes 7 sur 7
ce résultat surprenant en fait
s'explique par le fait que dans le sud
de la chine
les exploitations sont très petites et
n'ont pas pu augmenter leur production
n'ont pas pu augmenter leur productivité
et donc c'est le nord plus aride qui a
réussi à le faire mais bien sûr au prix
de l'assèchement du fleuve jaune a
sèchement dont on peut se demander s'il
ne va pas continuer voire même
s'amplifier dans les années à venir
nous voyons donc aujourd'hui contre
toute attente nous sommes tous
dépendants interdépendants delà de la
situation mondiale de l'eau quand j'ai
commencé à travailler dans le monde de
l'eau on avait coutume de dire que l'eau
était une ressource locale et que donc
l'eau devait être gérée localement
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que cette
vision des choses est totalement
dépassée mais l'interdépendance pour
l'eau a également des conséquences
pratiques pour nous tous car si nous
sommes interdépendants
nous sommes aussi des acteurs de la
crise mondiale de l'eau et nous sommes
partie prenante dans un grand nombre des
pénuries qu'on observe et donc nous
pouvons agir et nous pouvons princen
principalement agir en modifiant notre
comportement alimentaire nos habitudes
alimentaires
la première chose là aussi très
surprenante qu'on a découverte il y a
moins de 10 ans c'est qu'un tiers de la
nourriture produite aujourd'hui est
gaspillé un tiers de la nourriture
produite ça représente plus de cinquante
mille 50 nil qui chaque année s'évapore
sont perdus bien sûr ne tient qu'à nous
d'essayer de réduire ses pertes et
gaspillages
cela permettrait sans doute d'améliorer
la situation de l'eau dans d'autres pays
et également de fournir des solutions
pour tous les gens qui souffrent
aujourd'hui de malnutrition mais nous
pouvons aussi aller plus loin nous
pouvons également modifier notre
consommation de viande
il s'agit pas forcément de devenir
végétarien mais aujourd'hui dans la
plupart des pays européens les pays dits
développés
la plupart la plus grande partie de de
lui la plus la plus grande partie de
l'eau en fête et de notre nourriture qui
sert à fournir à alimenter les animaux
et les de manière totalement industriels
nous pourrions totalement essayez de
manger de la viande produits dans de
bonnes conditions par exemple des
animaux nourris à l'herbe est également
réduire de moitié les quantités d'eau
deviennent des quantités de viande que
nous mangeons carlo ms nous recommande
justement de réduire et de diminuer par
deux notre consommation de viande
je crois que si nous faisions cela nous
y gagnerions en santé et la planète
aussi je vous remercie